lo que tengo frente a mí es la
herramienta de khan academy para medir
ángulos eso es solo una parte que tengo
aquí en pantalla y ese es un ejercicio
bastante interesante y de hecho
agradezco a las personas que colaboraron
haciendo esta herramienta ya que es un
transportador virtual y lo podemos usar
para medir ángulos en general cuando
queremos medir ángulos lo que queremos
hacer es tomar este transportador y
colocar el centro del transportador en
el vértice central del ángulo así más o
menos el vértice del ángulo debe
coincidir con el centro del
transportador y lo que queremos hacer es
coincidir un lado del ángulo con el lado
cero del transportador así que vamos a
moverlo a rotar nuestro transportador un
poco para que coincida la marca del cero
con uno de los lados de nuestro ángulo
el otro lado del ángulo debe de quedar
dentro de nuestro transportador así que
vamos a tratar de hacer esto vamos a
rotar nuestro transportador virtual
vamos a hacer que coincida la marca del
cero con este lado del ángulo así que lo
movemos lo jalamos aquí con el ratón
poco a poco
ahí vamos ahí vamos ahí vamos a ver ahí
está así que un lado quedó en la marca
del 0 y el otro nos está indicando
dentro del transportador cuál es la
medida del ángulo este otro lado nos
apunta muy cercanamente a la marca de
los 20 grados así que yo ingreso esto en
la pantalla no lo están viendo pero
ingreso que es un ángulo de 20 grados
la respuesta fue correcta así que nos da
otro ángulo vamos a tratar de medirlo lo
tomamos lo movemos para que coincida su
vértice con el centro del transportador
o que está el vértice y ahora tenemos
que derrotarlo para que el lado coincida
con la marca de cero grados de nuestro
transportador vamos a hacer que coincida
con este lado del ángulo un poquito más
ahí está y vemos que el otro lado del
ángulo termina en 110 grados y
recordando lo que vimos el vídeo
anterior este que es un ángulo mayor de
90 grados es un ángulo obtuso el ángulo
anterior que fue menor a 90 grados será
un ángulo agudo esta va a ser la
respuesta esto lo voy a escribir como
resultado vamos hacer un par más de
éstos
vamos a tomar este otro ángulo y vamos a
medirlo con el transportador hacemos
coincidir el vértice con el centro del
transportador rotamos nuestro
transportador para que coincida la marca
del 0 con este lado del ángulo y este
otro lado va a ser un poquito más arriba
de 80 grados si queremos ser muy
precisos puede ser de 81 u 82 grados 80
es mi respuesta le escribo estuvo bien
vamos a hacer otro problema nuevamente
tomo mi transportador hago que el centro
coincida con el vértice del ángulo
después pongo un lado del ángulo que
coincida con la marca del cero del
transportador lo roto aquí más o menos
poco a poco
si lo dejáramos aquí esto no me serviría
ya que el otro lado del ángulo no está
dentro de la medida del transportador
entonces no podría saber exactamente a
dónde está apuntando siempre voy a
buscar que un lado del ángulo quede
dentro del transportador y el otro que
era en la marca del 0 en la otro lado
terminal me va a quedar o me está
marcando 70 grados lo escribo aquí mi
ángulo de 70 grados y vamos a dejar los
ejercicios hasta aquí y más adelante
veremos qué podemos hacer con los
ángulos ahora que ya sabemos cómo
medirlo